to my my you know you in this country
you come from a long there's a legacy of
kind of mainstream entertainers like you
from Danny LaRue to Dame Edna to Lilli
Savage but even here in Britain people
are a bit if not freaked out they're
kind of confused
by the beard why do you think the beard
is such a big deal actually I don't
really well I know it is something like
you don't see every day so but I created
this period lady just to show everybody
did you it's so cheesy but it just got
one life you know and you better make it
fabulous and that's just my own truth
and I feel this stage persona and I felt
more comfortable on stage and beside
that you know I'm a member of the gay
community and our stories are similar
and being a teenager in this small
village wasn't the funniest thing on
earth so over the years I tried to fit
in and I've changed myself in every
every way you can imagine I just wanted
to be part of the game and and then I
realized well I I create the game yeah
the wonderful thing about what you you
there um and as you say you don't see
this every day but a it's amazingly
glamorous bu you completely inhabit your
skin so beautifully and I think you
raise so many questions but you're also
all the answers that's what's so great
about you there's no bad so you know
consider first you're everywhere you're
on all the papers you're all of the
internet so what is your plan now have
you made a plan yet no I don't
okay tik-tok be making a plan our our
society is so fast you know and
everything is so so quick yeah so we
really try to you know sit back and look
and watch and choose wisely so did you
do have material from album already was
that all there already or you're gonna
have to write new song oh I have to to
make new stuff because yeah there are
some songs but you know I
my goal is a grammy so these songs
should better be good
yeah yeah seer writes good song yeah oh
yeah yeah no I think America what
America is already though you know cuz
so many it's weird because America
doesn't really pay attention to the
Eurovision but America's gone mad for
you so long as you are just gonna
Heathrow and go there oh right your song
yeah
I mean come on yeah you should or you
could represent the UK at your vision
next year
big big big
I yield like that very elegant in some
way me truly it looked and I say